hey everybody time for another movie
retrospective yeah this one was actually
a gift to us from one of our listeners
and our patrons Rob yeah thanks Rob
thank you very much and I'm actually
really glad that he sent this one
because this is one that I saw a lot on
cable when I was little yeah and I
remembered the title of it and I
remembered vaguely like a couple of
scenes but I didn't remember all that
much about it but I but the title like I
remembered it all these years later so
it must have made some kind of
impression at the time but I haven't
seen it since then yeah if you guys
wants to review something and we don't
have it you can send it to us and we'll
review it yeah yeah something burned or
if it's even if it's a factory copy even
better yeah I'll put that in my
collection cuz like I said I mean we try
to um you know cuz I know we try to do
like everybody's suggestions and stuff
like that sometimes some movies are
easier for us to get than others yeah I
usually like to do ones that were on my
list from a long time ago when they turn
up on shutter and I'm like oh let's do
that one recently a few months back
somebody requested Xanadu I'm looking at
that on blu-ray gore man
$10 was an Adu on blu-ray I can vaguely
remember that move you had to do the
Greek goddesses and stuff coming down
from now yeah I escaped Olivia I don't
remember being that good but maybe I
might like it now you might just kind of
disco yeah got like you know grease it
might be fun and you know you must
grease
I like grease in it you know sergeant
pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band I love
that movie even though it's terrible
it's terrible but I love it anyway yeah
but when you're when you're drinking or
maybe or maybe smoke and something you
know that shit's looking awesome to
watch well yeah yeah if you're in a good
mood yeah yeah yeah so the movie that
prob sent us is called silent scream or
the silent scream sometimes called it
now this is not to be confused I think
there was a Doctor Who episode called
silent scream and there was also I'm
pretty sure there was like an anti
abortion like PSA that was also called
the silent scream this is not that this
is actually a sort of a slasher movie
from 1979-1980 I although I hesitate to
call it a slasher movie it does have
some of the slasher movie tropes to it
as an Achilles talking teenagers imma
let do the heavy lifting on this one cuz
I said we watched it together but we
watched a lot of stuff recently and this
one really didn't stand out to me well
he's always kind of like on his tablet -
what this thing that's on what the movie
is depends on what it is so this movie I
remembered it from being very samey and
not really standing out - maybe you
liked it yeah yeah it's very it's
obviously an homage to psycho so it's
more like I said it's more psychological
thriller than slasher not that many
people like the body count is not very
high and the kills are not very graphic
it's kind of more a sort of just spooky
atmosphere type thing with a couple of
kills in it and it does have kind of a
Hitchcockian sort of then we're gonna
spoil it - yeah I remember certain
scenes from it but it blended in with
someone so many of the other ones that
we saw during that during that little
arrow that we were watching a lot of
movie I mean we always watch a lot of
movies but sometimes I mean like
sometimes I'll you know stop work for
the day and then it'll only be like 7
o'clock at night and then we'll just
watch like three or four movies like in
a row and then we'll just get drunk and
then all fall asleep this movie is very
much a product of its time
yeah it's of its era and we grew up
during this time and there are certain
tropes and certain visual things that
kind of for us be O'Connor they either
stand out is something really good or
it's the opposite they kind of blend off
into the background and you all kind of
go I'll kind of go into neutral
sometimes yeah yeah I mean but that's
what kind of happened with this movie
yeah for me it really didn't stick out
as anything super special but you were
you were enjoying it so yeah just
because I didn't remember liking it you
know I'm not gonna say hey let's not do
the review the fascinating thing about
this movie and I didn't know this until
after I saw that this actually never
would have occurred to me that the movie
was actually some of it was shot in 1977
but then
toward the director whose name was Denny
Harris after he screened it he's like
this is unreleasable what am I gonna do
then he brought in these two
screenwriting brothers the wheat
brothers who actually I think they went
on to work on some of the nightmare and
Elm Street movies and [ __ ] like that and
told him to like retool it and then most
of the movie was reshot like only the
movie that you see now only 15 percent
of that was part of the original version
so these like they brought in a whole
new actors they got rid of a whole other
actors it's just like well so the fact
that it hangs together as like a
narrative is amazing to me so I mean all
of this [ __ ] that's it like you know
because there's like some famous people
in this [ __ ] Barbara [ __ ] steel
isn't it I love her Barbara steel is in
it
Yvonne De Carlo is in it yeah Cameron
Mitchell market quality right there I
kind of love that cavity's it's of
shit-ass movies but he's in it so but
they didn't come on until later I don't
have any idea like what the original
version of this I've heard that it was
like much sleazier that there was like
rapes and [ __ ] involved so I guess they
decided to just go in a different
direction like I said more in a psycho
or psychological thriller type of
direction which I think was probably a
good idea because you know we had enough
of the sleazy kind of [ __ ] so like I
said even though the 15 percent of it
that was originally shot that was shot
in 1977 but then the movie actually
didn't come out until 1978 and 1979
rather and I think then it only played
like in a couple of theaters and then it
got like a little bit of a regional
release like in 1980 but it actually
ended up making like 15 mil not bad and
it is tossed that much to make and then
I don't know that might have been like
from rental and stuff like that too
but because it didn't really get a wide
release or anything I remember seeing it
like on HP hours yeah that's probably
where it made most of its money yeah cuz
I used to show it all the time like on
HBO because I'm sure the brights were
probably pretty cheap to get but okay so
this was actually shot at various
locations in Southern California the
mansion where they shot it is actually
quite cool it's like overlooking that
at Goshen I'm sure the interior may be a
different place but it kind of concerns
there's this perky college student her
name is Scottie Parker and she has the
very the patented like [ __ ] [ __ ]
hair day that's [ __ ] what's that
Dorothy
the Dorothy Hamill flip she's a big old
bug eyes sunglasses and [ __ ] like that
little midriff shirt and early
bell-bottoms and whatnot so she goes
she's going to college she goes to like
the Registrar's Office or whatever it is
and she's like oh the housing and
they're like [ __ ] she should have been
here like two weeks ago there's no more
housing for you [ __ ] off you know what I
mean she was the lady at the Registrar's
Office is very good she is okay she's
not having it so she's basically like
well here's a list of places you can go
and try to find an apartment and get out
of my face it's like we can't since
these aren't sanctioned by the college
we can't vouch for their quality or
anything like that so she's basically
like get out of here and then there's
like a cute little montage of Scottie
trying to find an apartment and it's
funny because she she looks like so
wholesome she doesn't look like [ __ ]
or nothing like that but in a couple
places she goes like some you know
pretty old woman alok open the door and
go like no you can't live here you [ __ ]
or whatever like that's what her face is
saying so she ends up at this creepy
mansion now this creepy mansion is owned
by the angles family and it's a mom
who's played by Yvonne De Carlo and if
you didn't know that that was a von de
Carlo okay Lily mom didn't recognize her
she's unrecognizable
so it's her and hits her creepy ass
nerdy son Mason who's like this big
cocky being pole type of thing with like
a really really bad haircut and he is
like so creepy that he might as well
have red herring tattooed across his for
ya because I mean and like I said I am
gonna spoil this even though he does I
think they kind of try to set it up so
like you think that he's the killer but
they're so obviously trying to set that
up that you're like he's not the killer
because you know what I mean because
he's introduced so early in the movie
that you're like that's not him at camp
yeah now he does know who the kill
is though but he's not the killer like
he's involved but he's not yeah so I got
him confused with the guy who they set
up in the other movie to be the the
child molester which movie are we
talking about there's a murder that I
remember that uh that Italian flick that
it was done in Louisiana oh the Lucchese
yeah yeah I kind of got him confused
yeah okay so all of them are boring
they're kind of learned together yeah
like I said we tend to like drink and
watch horror that night and sometimes if
we watch three or four yeah
like sometimes I've sometimes the next
day I'm like wait what did we even watch
yeah and like subscribers would be
messaging me and stuff so so me being on
the tablet it's not like I'm not working
I am working I'm talking to you guys
yeah yeah about you know future shows or
just top other topics yeah exactly but
yes and sometimes after a few drinks
some of these 70s and 80s movies can
start to blur together yeah and you know
a lot of a lot of watching a movie has
to do with your mood
yeah I might be able to go back and see
this movie again and like it but at the
time I was I remember being bored with
it I get that a lot it's like sometimes
you have to be in the right frame of
mind for particular movies I'm like I'm
usually in the mood for a horror movie
because I I never get sick of him I
could just watch him all the time but
sometimes I'm in the mood for like a
monster movie or a killer type movie and
sometimes I want like a creepy like
Slayer and ghost story you know what I
mean once I never get bored with or the
[ __ ] really terrible Italian ones
like Bronx Warriors those remember that
[ __ ] was kind of like a fake escape from
New York yeah yeah that 110 pound kid
walking around like a badass Miss
Mitchell show and it was trash oh it was
terrible she was terrible everybody had
great names in that I actually saw that
one I saw escape mm which it was either
a sequel or prequel to that one because
it was on Mystery Science Theater that
was actually one of the best episodes
they did that movie was [ __ ]
hilarious yeah they're if they're really
bad I love them well yeah there there's
a certain entertaining quality about yes
you
for shitty they have been sharknado
effect right
matter-of-fact from that see what's name
that company did sharknado oh [ __ ] now I
can't remember they do all that all the
ten most terrible movies they're all
manic romantic wreck
yeah yeah the new MST did that movie I
ordered today I ordered their
masterpiece Nazis at the center of the
earth I love that movie that movie is so
bad that it's awesome
that was I didn't think about at all I
thought it was like a [ __ ] blast yes
empty every Nazi stereotype is a dress
and it's just it's so ridiculous yet it
is thrill thrill energy center hollow
earth theories royal flying saucers on
it and I think Antarctica wasn't that
mentioned I think's just every [ __ ]
wacky Nazi stereotype Nazi trope is in
is in the movie yeah that's great it's
super fun yeah well yeah NATO even yeah
I like sharknado but it was a little
uneven yeah but like I said you gotta
watch when you're like trying to make a
bad movie it's hard to try to make it
better we're gonna do Nazis at the same
it has to happen by accident
we will do Nazis at the center of the
earth when oh yeah we'll definitely do
that when it gets here but yeah so
Scotty moves into this house there's
also three other college students that
are also living there and one of the
other ones is Doris who's like a cute
little chunky girl and there's also
Peter and Jack no I think Peter is the
one yeah they're both kind of douchey
but like Peter is like the douchier one
because he's always like my dad will pay
for this my dad and I'm just like oh boy
here we go
he's one of those like all that but you
know since they're the only dudes around
the house the girls like pair off with
them so they start going to see what
happened back in the sack I guess so
it's just like well you're there so yeah
that's definitely what was going on
honestly though I feel like poor Doris
got like the [ __ ] end of the deal
because she ended up with [ __ ] Peter
yeah and he was like not only was like
douchey like I have money blah blah blah
but he's also like
he's also kind of rapey it was the
pre-aids era yeah
they had all the girls tracked tricked
into free love trick Amanda bit yeah
come on don't you want to be cool yeah
with everybody yeah share not share
alike okay we're not even drinking today
this is nice coffee we're just like this
is over all right
but yeah so they end up you know going
on a double date or whatever Peter gets
like super handsy with Doris on the
beach and she's just like nah bro and
like knocks his ass out and I was like
woohoo you go girl and then she like
[ __ ] leaves him on the beach and his
stupid ass gets stabbed
is anyone sorry no so um and then here's
the fucked-up thing the dude gets
stabbed and then like the next day I
think it was Scotty's little boyfriend
who's name is Jack I think he's like hey
let's go down to the beach and make out
she's like do you mean where our friend
just got murdered like eight hours ago
awesome yeah let's totally do that okay
that'll put me in the mood yeah yeah
he's like but it's such a good beach the
beach can't help with it somebody
murdered on it it was another era but
fine I mean at least she was just kind
of like yeah but then she went along
with that cuz you know yeah she's girl
you go along what do you do so that so
they end up the thing or whatever now
Doris meanwhile she's pretty freaked out
I mean she didn't like love Peter or
nothing like that she just met the dude
but she was like he did get stabbed and
that's kind of weird and she felt kind
of bad cuz she left him on the beach
even though he was being a rapey douche
um so she's down in the laundry room
talking to Scotty and she says you know
I'm gonna move out of this house cuz I
don't like this chick which is a
reasonable thing to do she's like you
know I don't somebody got murdered
that's not cool so she's like and I'm
kind of creeped out like there's a
murderer running around here couldn't
you stay down in the laundry room with
me and keep me company because it's
creepy it's down in the basement just
like I never have to said of a haunting
and Scotty like an [ __ ] she goes
now I have stuffed I have studying to do
then proceeds to go up to a room and
have sex with Jack
and Doris gets murdered yeah in the
laundry room thanks Scotty yeah getting
laid was more important yeah than your
friend getting stabbed today what's back
then one I guess yeah so yeah that whole
thing happens now as the movie goes on
you discover like I said they're really
trying to set it up like creepy-ass
Mason because he's always like watching
them and he's like watching rapey [ __ ]
on TV and he's like you know creepily
eating a sandwich and like watching them
have sex and all they're kind of you
know what I mean he's just being
obviously mmm
creepy so so they're trying to set him
up as the killer but you know that it's
so obviously he can't be but they
started to think that there's maybe
somebody else in the house now as it
turns out as Scotty investigates she
finds out that Mason had a sister and
nobody knew what happened to the sister
but it turns out that she's been living
like she's been walled up and not walled
up I guess she can get out but yeah she
can get out obviously cuz she's killing
people but um so she's been like walled
up in this house and nobody knew she was
there and it took like forever for the
cops to find out about it because what
happened was okay so the sister who's
played by Barbara Steele and like I said
I love Barbara Steele she does not say a
single word in this movie
she's completely she plays it completely
silently and she is awesome and scary so
what happened to her was that she got
pregnant and tried to hang herself but
she survived and then she went mental
and then it turns out that even though
Mason thought that Barbara Steele was
his sister that was actually his mom so
Yvonne De Carlo was actually is grandma
so there was that whole [ __ ] up family
[ __ ] going on now so she went crazy and
she couldn't talk because it [ __ ] up
her larynx or whatever when she tried to
hang herself and they took her like the
mom like took her out of the psychiatric
woman like hit her in the house and so
then for whatever reason and Mason even
says to Ivana Carlo he's
why the [ __ ] did you let all these
college students stay here if you knew
she was up there and was getting all
murdery and she's just like cuz it's fun
my bad well sure she's like I needed
money we're gonna lose the house he's
like a great candidate for like [ __ ]
case cinema a giant [ __ ] case yeah his
show I really do love that show yeah so
funny yeah the I don't think this is I
don't think this is bad enough because
this is actually I think this is
actually a fairly well made movie like I
said it's more Hitchcock II and it's not
really a slasher here you tell it it's
hilarious
I know but yeah it likes here well yeah
yeah but so that will [ __ ] happens and
you know everything turns out okay
you know Scottie lives Jack lives and
everybody that's a bad guy gets killed
oh you know even though it took like
cops like [ __ ] forever now like I
said I find it amazing this movie is
only 87 minutes long I find it amazing
that it hangs together so well even
though it's two movies it's essentially
two movies I mean there was even there
was this actress that was in a Diane
something I think her name was and she
was supposed to be like a police
lieutenant or something like that and
she had like shot the role and then
later on like in the later version of
the movie they cut her part completely
out because they said a female police
lieutenant was unbelievable so yeah so
they got Cameron Mitchell instead who
was in it for maybe like two days or
something and that I heard he got like
$500 for being there for two days a
meson you remember uh female police
officers in the seventies I don't well I
don't really they were back in the 70s I
was out in California and they were all
dudes with mustaches yes way to kind of
men wear mustaches back the 70s cops and
gay cops yeah yeah I guess high speed
shock absorber for a [ __ ]
yeah but yeah so you know so the fact
that and it's funny too because even
though you could say this is like kind
of cheesy and stuff but what they did
was camera Mitchell's thing at the end
where the cops finally like figure this
[ __ ] out come to the house find the dead
people all over the place like Mason and
the sister and everything and what they
did was they took that end part where he
discovers all the bodies they slowed it
down like and put that footage at the
beginning like as a cold open like over
the credits and I'm like oh nice like
double use of footage they're like
normally I would think that was like
cheesy and you know like cheap but it
worked because you didn't know the
context of it like when you saw in the
beginning and it was just like during
the credits and you're like oh my god
all these [ __ ] bloody people like up
here in this attic what the [ __ ]
happened here but then at the end do you
find out what happened so it is kind of
cheap but I thought it was justified and
maybe and they pulled it off pretty well
I thought so like I said this is a movie
that I saw a lot on cable growing up
this one My Bloody Valentine like all
those ones I remember that one this was
like all around that time cuz I was you
know I've loved her or maybe I was a
little kid it's like I said hey this is
a very forgettable movie there was a
little snippet 7 I remembered yeah from
seen on cable yeah I'd forgotten it even
back then I don't think I saw it very
many times yeah you know might have been
something that was playing in the
background mostly yeah because I
remember there were a few scenes that
kind of stood out I was like oh yeah I
remember that one but the movie as a
whole I had forgotten it my favorite
part of it is Barbara Steele I think she
is easily the best part of this movie
and obviously you don't see much Myrtle
to end because you don't know that she's
in the house she's like living up there
secretly and one of the coolest things
about it is that in her room she has you
know like a dresser with a mirror on it
except the mirror is a picture of her
when she was young so she's like not
even looking and she's like sit there
since there looks at it like it's a
which i think is like pretty cool but
like I said she doesn't say anything in
this but she's still you know I'm not
sure I'm not quite sure how old she
wasn't used when horribly old but she
still looks really good in this and she
plays a crazy person so well that she
doesn't even have to like say anything
so she is easily like the highlight of
this movie and I'm glad that you know
when they redid it from you know the
footage that they shot in 1977 that they
actually got her they got a Vaughn to
Carlo and they got some actual actors to
kind of you know get to class this thing
up and like I said you know I think it
was the right choice to go in a more
psycho direction rather than like a
slasher direction yeah so you know like
I said this this is one that I saw a lot
on cable growing up and I remembered the
title of it and I remembered a couple
scenes but I didn't remember like the
whole thing like I didn't remember the
story or what happened in it so I'm
happy that I got to revisit it because I
really like to revisit things that I saw
back then yeah this was this goes dead
and buried no likes dead and buried a
lot there I had forgotten all about dead
and buried until we got it and saw it
yeah we didn't get it on shudder yeah we
saw that that I saw that and I
remembered every frame of it once it
started rolling yeah I'd forgotten all
about that movie yeah if you guys want
to see a badass movie go looking dead
and bury yeah we did a review of it
didn't review of it another one that's
on shudder that I really liked as a kid
and then I Sabri saw again recently and
I think it's on shudder is stage fright
that's actually an Italian movie but
it's dubbed into English and I might do
a review on that one's ever liked that
one a lot didn't Barry came out after
this one but not by a long few years
yeah what it wouldn't be like he - right
81 82 but dead buried was memorable even
though I forgot the title of it but as
soon as I saw it again I remembered
every because that was a crazy creepy
ass premise yeah you know what I mean
guy making zombies a crazy premise cuz
they're like a weird or original premise
cos yeah weird but it's funny to like
what things stick with you when you're a
kid and what things don't you know what
I mean yeah it's funny too because when
I remembered I mentioned My Bloody
Valentine before I'm not talking about
the remake the remake wasn't bad I
actually did see the remake but the
their original from 1981 um I saw that
when I was 9 or 10 years old and that
scared the [ __ ] out of me when I was
little oh my god that scared me so bad
but then I watched it like over and over
cuz I'm glad we saw Friday 13th part 1 &
2 yeah and one was still kind of scary
in a way because nowhere near as scary
as I remember it wasn't as gory as I
remembered it I remembered it being it
really gory but it's not it yeah and
then funny part 2 was still good
I liked the Murrays sucked yeah part 2
part 3 sucked and I remembered likin
that as a kid I liked it too at the time
yeah but you see it now your side but I
saw some really good movie I mean it was
terrible I liked wanted to yeah I think
three kind of killed the Friday the 13th
they kept going but they got worse if
you ask me but no I guess they got a
little bit better
three is bad yeah he is very I had
forgotten about it being that bad yeah
I'm like cuz honestly back in the day I
saw up to number seven or eight when
they came out and then I just didn't buy
cuz I'm like but Jason's going to space
yeah
and like I didn't what but I watched it
recently and it was terrible but I was
entertained yeah it doesn't take much
but in this area unnecessary the ones
that stuck stuck with me were like dead
and buried the tenant the one
burnt-offerings
yeah yeah the book is also awesome by
robert moresco what's the one yeah okay
burnt-offerings yeah what else there was
another one from that time man there's
there was there are a lot better I still
want to do a review on ghost story
because I love that movie that was 81
and also that's one of my favorite books
too yeah they took a lot out of you know
obviously because the book is like
looking a doorstop and they had to make
it to our movie out of it so they had to
cut a lot of it out but I mean the
change length The Changeling yeah yeah
that's also on shutters um
the evil oh you know that was later yeah
I think that was evil might have been
around 83 that really and I had actually
didn't see that at the time when we do
or did a review of it I might have
mentioned on the review that reminded me
very strongly of Hell House yeah
the legacy yeah like that one with the
Satanists yeah that was a good one The
Sentinel yeah we need to do a review on
the Sentinel I need to get that yeah
because I haven't seen that a long time
and I remember that being scary you
should too yeah but yeah so like I said
if you're into kind of psychological
thrillers from 70s and you haven't seen
silent scream cuz it's I feel like it
might be at a printer it's kind of like
hard to get nowadays um then check it
out you might really like it like I said
don't expect it to be super boring or
nothing like that because it's not only
a couple people get killed and that's
not gory there's I think there's two
titties in it but that's about it I do
the other two yeah yeah we definitely
will do that guy I also love that movie
and I love that book yeah that was a
weird really good um so yeah and thank
you again very much Rob for sending us
silent scream that was very awesome of
you and remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and the sidebar where you can go to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation and remember our movie
retrospectives just like this one here
come out every Friday and our 13 o'clock
matinee three new movies in the theater
come out every Sunday and our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday so check
them all out we will see you next time
bye